[Music]
you notice shortness of breath and a
stark pain in your chest you might have
lost your taste and smell and your
breathing like you just walked up three
flights of stairs these symptoms signal
a trip to the emergency department of
your local hospital how will you be
treated when would you be put on a
ventilator and how could you develop a
severe case of kovat 19
despite being perfectly healthy before
you rush in call your doctor or hospital
ahead of time and describe your symptoms
you'll want to do this because your
local emergency clinic might not have
enough beds and may need to direct you
to another facility or
your symptoms might not be considered
severe enough yet to require treatment
at the hospital so it's best to check by
phone first but once you are admitted
nurses will give you a copepod 19 test
most patients will also have a set of
blood tests taken from their veins
doctors will then listen to your lungs
and check the levels of oxygen in your
blood with a clip-on finger monitor why
are they doing that because if you have
severe kovat 19 symptoms the oxygen
levels in your blood can drop too low
since this can result in
life-threatening damage to your vital
organs you'll get oxygen to breathe
through two small tubes that go just
inside your nostrils or through a
facemask you'll then get a chest x-ray
or a CT scan so that doctors can get a
better understanding of which areas of
your lungs are inflamed a CT scan also
known as a computerized axial tomography
is a painless diagnostic test that uses
x-rays and computers to create
cross-sectional images of your body a CT
scanner is a large square or round x-ray
machine with a tunnel through the center
it helps doctors see into your lungs
during your CT scan you will lie on a
table that slowly passes through the
tunnel a giant ring called a gantry will
rotate around your body it contains a
tubes that release
x-ray beams and detectors that will
measure the amount of radiation absorbed
by your body and these beams will
capture many views of your body from
different angles as the gantry spins the
detectors will send data to a computer
that creates cross-sectional images or
3d models of your lungs helping doctors
diagnose the severity of your
coronavirus infection once your doctors
have all the data to determine the
progress of your kovat 19 infection what
treatments can improve your condition
well some patients may get standard
antibiotics these won't fight the
coronavirus directly but could be
beneficial if you develop an additional
bacterial infection in your lungs but
because there is no approved medicine
specifically for kovat 19 you'll be
relying on your immune system to fight
off the virus and hope that oxygen
therapy combined with supportive care
can help your body recover if things go
your way your immune system will start
to produce antibodies to slowly kill the
virus but what happens if your condition
worsens if the oxygen concentration in
your blood then drops below critical
levels doctors can escalate your
treatment to something called high flow
nasal oxygen which means that a machine
will be pushing air into your nose
warmed to body temperature and
humidified with sterile fluid you can
get up to 60 liters of oxygen per minute
and up to 100% concentration if high
flow nasal oxygen is not an option or
didn't help doctors will start you on
mechanical ventilation in a last
life-saving effort you will be given
medication via IV to put you to sleep
the first step in mechanical ventilation
is called endotracheal intubation once
you're asleep your doctor will use an
instrument called a laryngoscope this
device helps guide the endotracheal tube
to its proper position your doctor will
tilt your head back slightly and insert
the laryngoscope through your mouth and
down into your throat taking special
care to avoid contact
with your teeth using a special blade on
the device your doctor will gently raise
the epiglottis which is a flap of tissue
protecting your larynx as they advance
the tip of the endotracheal tube into
the trachea once the tube is in place
your doctor will inflate a small balloon
surrounding the tube to make sure it
remains snugly in place they will then
remove the laryngoscope and tape the
tube to the corner of your mouth to
prevent it from being jostled out of
position your doctor will check to see
that the tube is properly positioned in
the lower part of the windpipe by
inflating your lungs with a special bag
and listening for breathing sounds on
both sides of your chest if the end of
the tube is too low both lungs will not
receive the same amount of air in some
cases an x-ray is taken immediately
after intubation to confirm the
placement of the tube once the
endotracheal tube is in the proper
position your doctor will attach it to
the mechanical ventilator which will
have a specially designed pump that aids
respiration by delivering well
oxygenated air into the lungs and
permitting carbon dioxide to escape
levels of oxygen and carbon dioxide will
be closely monitored to confirm that the
ventilator is working properly at the
beginning of the outbreak some hospitals
were putting patients on ventilators
early on in their treatment this was due
in part to concerns that less invasive
ventilation procedures could cause viral
particles to disperse into the air with
more cases of kovat 19-2 study health
professionals are attempting to set
guidelines for different types of
respiratory failure and who ventilator
treatment would be best suited for this
includes recommendations such as placing
patients on their stomachs called prone
positioning which evidence suggests
helps increase the amount of oxygen
that's getting to their lungs so with
all this in mind why does this virus
cause only mild disease in most people
but could turn fatal for you despite
being healthy in such a case it seems
the worst damage may be caused by an
abnormal immune response to the
infection rather than by the virus
itself in simplified terms when any cell
in your body senses that there is
something foreign in this case a virus
the immediate response of the cell is to
kill itself a protective mechanism to
prevent it from spreading to other cells
the way this happens is that cells in
your immune system called macrophages
release small signaling proteins called
cytokines certain kinds of these trigger
cell death when many cells are doing
this at the same time a lot of tissue
can die this is what medical
professionals call a cytokine storm in
kovat 19 this means that lung tissue
breaks down and the walls of the lungs
tiny air sacs leak fluid through causing
pneumonia and starving the blood of
oxygen most of your cells in the tissue
will die as a result of this
uncontrolled level of cytokines it eats
away at your lungs to a point where they
cannot recover your body is now
attacking itself cytokine storms are
becoming a common occurrence in kovat 19
patients with severe symptoms and they
seem to play a role in death in a large
number of cases whether you would
develop a cytokine storm may depend on
genetic factors patients in studies with
the h1n1 influenza virus who developed
cytokine storm syndrome often possessed
subtle genetic immune defects resulting
in the uncontrolled immune response now
you are more likely to have developed
these genetic immune defects as you age
but there is also a small chance that
you might have a genetic predisposition
to developing cytokine storms after
infection with the novel coronavirus
it's important to mention that the
complete picture of cytokine storms is
not yet well understood and the medical
community is still early in
understanding the many aspects of the
disease
a lot of findings and hypotheses need to
be confirmed in more and larger clinical
studies but the good news is that many
clinical trials are underway to explore
treatments used for other conditions
that could halt cytokine storms and
fight kovat 19:00 as well as to develop
new ones
there are currently hundreds of clinical
trials of proposed kovat 19 drugs
already recruiting patients so if you're
lucky enough and make it through all
this you'll be weaned off the ventilator
you'll probably feel extremely exhausted
but you can now step down from critical
care to a normal hospital ward where
you'll stay until you can maintain safe
oxygen levels by just breathing air
after that you can be discharged go home
and be reunited with your loved ones
[Music]
this video was a collaboration with the
what if channel where we usually dive
into the hypothetical scenarios about
the human body humanity our planet and
the cosmos check out our channel by
visiting the link in the description
below